Nick would how often would you say you set up an ad in a niche and it never starts generating leads ratio between number of
ads set up to ones that become sellable
It does happen. Um
It's not happened a ton for me. So if you guys follow the due diligence process follow the metrics
You
Most likely will generate leads now. I will say that I have in the past been a little aggressive gotten a little cocky
Decided to test things out and i've gotten to where you know, i'm i'm doing stuff
It's a little too high on the cpc. I'm like, oh well if it's five bucks that seven is fine
Or ten is fine. I've also gone into markets that are really small just to test out
So it will happen, but it shouldn't be happening very often. I would say
like maybe uh less than
You know probably less than 15 percent of the time if you're having that happen on 50 percent of your campaigns
Then you're you're missing a step on selecting the niche